and now Clutterbuck R wide and Holstrom
time for the league leading short handed
goals and Clutterbuck with a shot good save
by aluk Clutterbuck I think thought he had
one but he was denied on the play in the middle
of a change now he'll shoot that pass the Stick
of Connor and Connor will head off P pass
got off by rosmus kupari he delay shot and
knocked Away by soken as he had ey in front of
the that he's got it centering pass and be in
the night good save by sokan best chance so
far Tony n wins that draw now morisy P Ryder
good redirect on side is Tony n shot sto by
soken who came well out and the Jets are able
to keep that puck alive morrisy around for
Dello again Dello finding Adam Lowry they'll
look and find Kyle Connor leaves and sends it
back Mory snap shot change direction theard
scores the 11th goal of the season from Gabriel
valard and it's one- nothing Jets talk with the
early shots from the Jets just putting it to the
net and and let the goalie feel it in this one
again look at the cut back from Kyle Conor nice
job put feet looks like the knee's working and
then it's just a shot to an area from Josh morsy
and and a tip from the wand of valard it's more of
a magic wand than a stick all the way back for
AO 5 seconds left from the power play plays it
to Lee and he gave it back to him Riley Slap
Shot score a tip in front and it is Lee with
his 15th career goal in his 17th game against the
Jets and it's 1-1 a lot has to do with Andre Lee
he's a big man at 6'3 230 lbs this is where he
does his best work in tight Around the Net and
look at the way that he's not just standing there
but he arrives on time a timed tip that is just in
high fashion he tips the puck from where he came
from pulls that one in behind huk that is Magic
Nikolai eers over the logo dashing in curls
at the boards elers continues to hang on to
it Romanov challenges great pass Lowry fires and
a good save by soken nice work there by Nikolai
elers so good lately Lowry takes it gives it
back to him Mory is at the point under to go
now in the period Mory Wheeling with it sets it
up and Lowry shot Ricochet out front behind the
goal and the puck bouncing all over the place
as morisy tried to bank that one in Jets almost
took the lead back on the other side of that in
the second of back to backs the Islanders are 02
and three they're looking to get their first win
in a back-to-back scenario we look to strike here
Connor gets it gets a shot and valard denied him
the rebound and that is vintage Kyle Connor coming
on off that right wing that's a really good for
check from this fourth line that was led by Kari
to make the puck stop and then he gets above
it as well to force the Islanders to dump it
J get it back that play eers to Peretti and he
just kind of redirected it toward the net spun
and shot it the seven minute Mark of this second
period valard and Lee scoring in the first for
the Jets and Islanders respectively now Connor
has it slide to him slowly they keep it on side
Conor flicks it here's a Thrive by Valery what a
set up with a big stop by soken no doesn't look
like there's must rust on that 81 and blue Lowry
gets a better of that Collision play improving
here in Period two Horan rushing drags it shoots
kick save rebound and the Islanders could not get
that all important second shot F save by H Lee
doson stopped by hellar how did he make that
save looked like he got the stick on it and doson
can't believe it Dobson was Point Blank and what a
reaction from alach now Paul maray with a backand
stop by Conor huk doson gives it to barzel Dobson
open to his left again he'll use the right side
though now Dobson shoots tip one a stop by Halu
he's trying to stay strong in the blue ice and
an acrobatic save keeps this a one-1 game Schmidt
takes that pass he's got P to his right this
is Peretti Waits shoots and he rang that off
the side of the goal Jam play by n the cff now pon
Schmidt curling and taking it for fetty Pon scores
superb Puck it by the Jets and they lead it to
the one a broken soken I believe he loses his
blade this is a great catch from our truck
downstairs look at that it hits the toe of
his right foot so now he can't stand up he
stays down there as you can see no Edge no
Edge and this is an excellent job moving the
puck from side to side east west good recover
from domov and what a great shot from Neil Pon
whether he recognized soken had no Edge or not
doesn't matter it was a great shot good efficient
Puck movement of the Jets on the power play with
their third attempt get their lead back and what a
helpless feeling that had to be for Ilia soken as
we near the 18-minute mark in the second period
Jets looking for a win that we put them back in
first overall Dello steered it on goal stopped by
soken centering pass and they score and it's Mason
Appleton his first goal since November the 19th
and it's 3-1 Winnipeg and you get the sense of
relief from Mason where he hasn't scored in
a while one assist in his last seven games
and just great job to hunt the puck down from
Tony Nat and then you just go to the net three
guys wrapped all around it and then Appleton
that he keeps tight to that strong side and
this one may have gone off es skate we'll need
another look he don't care jets diing away at
it with Lowry now walstrom he made the cut move
lost the handle Lowry pulls it in had an assist
in the game's first goal there's a chance to
the front of the goal it's just chipped to the
corner as Romanov came off the Blue Line doesn't
get involved offensively much Lee now shoots and
scores somehow Anders Lee is able to tuck that
in off of H his second of the game makes it a
one goal game that heluk has made in the
degree of difficulty that he's made them
and in this one just barely a half a minute
into the period Helu looks like he's got that
strong side post completely sealed off and then
Anders Lee he's right on the goal line and he
banks it in off of the pad and some pad pardon
me and somehow this one squeaks in he has 16
goals in 19 games against the Jets crazy and
10 goals in the 10 games here in Winnipeg is
that shots blocked goce shot blocker save and
it's batted Away by Dello as Nikolai eers is
trying to pierce through the middle of the ice
on entry and Mayfield says no not on my watch
makes a good play and doesn't make it take a
penalty doing it here's Appleton with a slap
shot rebound need Ryder and he put it off the
goal post he had time pick this spot could not
get that two- goal lead back doubles back and
gives it to Pal Mary carefully over the line
leaving it for Nelson he'll drop it hel walks
up fires it redirected on goal heluk made the
save and it's picked away there by Tony n he had
to be careful a follow back for Dylan kapari has
sked well here tonight in his second game back
after injury aale aello shot stopped by soken
that's a big one right there with just under
six left in the third battling to get it one
more time too leans in on his man and that was
Horvat pass for barzel he gets knocked down on
the play and at the line kept in by Nelson but
it's going to be Kyle Conor into the empty net
stores defense of desperation from the Winnipeg
Jets there's the first stick from Conor and then
there's the second he stays from the south side
of the puck and singlehandedly makes two defens
of plays to get the puck out of trouble out
of his own and ice this one now the Jets have
scored four more goals 20 different times this
season they will be 20 and0 when doing so one
22 remain Jets dropped one on Saturday they had
their winning streak snap but they're back in the
W column tonight and they're back at top the NHL
standings they beat the Hors 4 to2 and it's all
over